[Applause]
hello texas
[Applause]
they came out in force to protest the
country's newest and most restrictive
abortion law abortions after a fetal
heartbeat is detectable at about six
weeks of gestation are now illegal in
texas that's before most women even know
they're pregnant i don't think that you
know
old
men should like politicians should be
making the decision like the decision of
what i can and can't do with my body
and
i think everyone like every woman should
have the right to decide when they want
to have kids and how they want to have
kids and how many
the texas law took effect in september
the bill that i'm about to sign that
ensures that the life of every unborn
child who has a heartbeat will be saved
from the ravages of abortion
the law offers a financial reward to
private citizens who successfully sue
anyone who performs or enables an
abortion in texas doctors nurses even
uber drivers are at risk of civil
penalties
attorney elizabeth meyers says she too
could be sued for representing abortion
clinics by the letter of the law i am in
violation of it
and the law is unconstitutional so it's
not really a law
what's your message to those who might
want to see you
bring it
a few thousand people have gathered at
the texas state capitol to protest the
ban they call it
unconstitutional and resulting in women
being forced to continue with unwanted
pregnancies or having to travel to other
states for abortions if they can afford
it
but eventually abortions may be banned
in all states that's the fear of
marchers who also rallied saturday in
washington and other major u.s cities
they worry the country's supreme court
is poised to overturn roe versus wade
the landmark case that gave american
women the right to an abortion in 1973.
julia kirkland says she had an abortion
years ago when doctors said her fetus
had a fatal medical condition
that same procedure would be illegal in
texas today there's a very real risk
that my uterus would have ruptured if i
weren't allowed to have the abortion
and although my life might have been
saved
i could never have had children after
that she went on to become a mother of
three by choice
she says she hopes other women will be
able to decide for themselves as well
heidi jo castro al jazeera austin texas
well wanna brooks is a civil rights
attorney she says large demonstrations
like these could change the course of
abortion laws
i do think it'll make a difference
as far as the dialogue and as far as
continuing to to keep attention on the
subject matter of course and for all of
those who are passionate about it but
will it make a difference as to what uh
the supreme court may ultimately do or
the judge that is currently uh dealing
with uh the the lawsuit brought by the
justice department that's difficult to
say um you know ideally or typically it
shouldn't make a difference um as far as
in the court of public opinion because
of course judges are supposed to be
neutral um however as we saw from the
supreme court um last month when they
when they failed to or rather they chose
not to um not to hear uh you know
whether or not that they should
interfere with the texas law and it was
a five to four vote and what what we did
see though is that they did leave a door
open to the possibility that they may in
fact entertain um hearing from
the justice department and making a
ruling on this in the future again on
face value theoretically it shouldn't
make a difference to judicial officers
who are supposed to be neutral but do i
think the court of public opinion has uh
carries weight of course it does of
course it does and people have been
extremely vocal and are very passionate
about this issue